[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
hello i'm frank epstein founder and
president
of collage new music it is my pleasure
to introduce to you our latest
online presentation entitled
the composer speaks the composer speaks
is an opportunity to introduce composers
directly to you
our guest today is john harbeson
a pulitzer prize-winning composer john
makes his home
in cambridge massachusetts he's a
professor of composition and chamber
music
at massachusetts institute of
technology's
department of music collage has
performed john's music for many years
and received a grammy nomination
for our recording of his epic song cycle
moteti di montale
the boston symphony commissioned and
premiered john's first
fifth and sixth symphonies
john is a wonderful composer and so
supportive
of his younger colleagues including
composers
vocalists and instrumentalists
john will be interviewed by music
director david hoos
we thank you all for joining us and we
hope this experience
will bring you closer to new music and
the composers
who write it
this is my little workroom in
actually rather palatial workroom in
cambridge massachusetts
where are you where you do most of your
work do you do your
composing and your score study there
pretty much practicing the piano really
actually yeah my work on my ba
art of the feud do you find yourself
playing the piano more
now that things are very isolated for
everyone
i think so i'm trying to also stay in
shape because
if we come out of this i've got my uh
my group at mit sin strength in numbers
has a couple of
gigs coming up and i find that the daily
bach
is probably very helpful practicing the
the art of the fugue is what keeps you
in shape for your jazz group
that's my my fantasy of the thing yes um
and uh it also i just find that
the fascination of how each piece is
getting harder
uh in that sequence um it it's almost
uh a fantasy that you get a finger on
each note even around number six
but um they are keyboard pieces and
uh i think it's important to um to keep
believing that
do you have a feeling that bach had to
practice his own
music or do you think his facility was
so great that
in fact the music he was writing just
fit
under his fingers i think his facility
was
already legendary and certainly he
expects
a tremendous amount of unusual
uh things to happen under the hands um
but i think that's one of the wonderful
things about those pieces they
don't act like piano music but they turn
out to be
uh realizable which i think is a
fascinating puzzle
fellow musician friend of both of ours
said to me
that she was practicing bach as well and
the thing she liked about bach was that
you could play it at any speed
true and it makes the early work on
something like the
are the few fuchs very uh satisfying
because at any speed
you feel they're making plenty of sense
and if you never got
any faster you'd be fine
you ordinarily lead a very busy life
obviously composing but teaching
conducting
um playing the viola playing piano in
your jazz group
and also you spend a good bit of your
time it seems to me
because i see you there going to
concerts
so some of those things activities not
your piano playing so
much but some of those activities are
stolen from us right now
which we hope is only momentary
so i'm wondering how
how this shutdown as it were has
touched your composing activity if at
all
has it just given you more time or less
inspiration or in what way has it
affected what you're doing
i think it seems i've talked to a lot of
people about their experiences it seems
similar to mine that
you lose more time when there
is more available time um
that's i think the puzzling part i think
overall i get about the same amount
accomplished
as if there were no uh covid
but um there is a lot of
space seems to get away and i'm not
quite sure where it goes
though some of it goes into interesting
pursuits i've found
i'm quite nimble about dropping
everything to
listen to more things some
someone mentioned to me that kutak's
opera was on youtube and i thought well
sure okay and i got out the
english language version of endgame
and followed it along quite well
on the youtube two and a half hours
later i'd heard the piece
um and i'm not sure i was in
under normal circumstances with a lot of
regular teaching and so forth i'm not
sure
i would do that i also got a tip on a
very distinguished performance of uh
of uh vendorizer which was going on in
music
from marlborough with
mark patmore and uh mitsuko ushida
and not having really listened to that
piece or thought about it until since i
coached it
with two mathematicians at mit about
three years ago i decided it was time
for another winterizer
and an hour and a half later i had made
it through
that piece goodness knows how we ever do
get through it
um and i think that's a that's a mark
of feeling like okay if something big
comes up you can do it
uh you have to you do have time
i i can't help asking what it was like
coaching two mathematicians in that
great song cycle
it was a wonderful experience they
were both musicians i had worked with on
numerous other things
actually uh the baritone in in
vocal ensemble and the pianist and lots
of standard chamber music
so i trusted them as hard-working
musicians
and they had prepared all summer
and they said okay now we're ready give
us a couple sessions and we'll perform
the piece
and i i had one session and i said no
we're actually going to spend quite a
lot of time
and we did about two songs a week for
the rest of that year
and the performance was postponed i
think about seven months
but it was wonderful are they happy with
that
i think at first they were a little
stymied and puzzled but eventually yes i
think they
they bought into the idea that in fact
this piece
takes more than a lifetime uh
and um and it was a good experience i
think for all of us it's
quite a lot for two musicians who are
not professionally
headed to be musicians and who
are both in some field of algebra where
they go to conferences where there's
only
them and seven other people who
understand what they're doing
so there's a meeting of minds there to
start with which is i think is good
but that they have have the kind of
enterprise as i've known for years to
invest tremendously in in a really quite
impassioned way
in projects like this uh um
it's nice to feel that the music has so
much hold
that something which has no professional
central
centrality to to them
still will absorb a huge amount of their
energy
which of course it certainly did
what turned out what turned out to be
the
uh the major issues that you
thought needed to be addressed in that
in that working period of seven months
the same issue that seems
always to be the primary issue in every
music that i coach with anyone
um pulse
steadiness of rhythmic impulse
and the power of uh
commitment to pulse in the support of
songs as
beautifully built as those songs
so i assume that you're saying that
doesn't mean that
the idea of rubato is um
an anathema but rather something more
sophisticated
oh yeah no but that there is there is
a tempo which is appropriate to the
character in the words
which is uh
operable and relevant through the piece
regardless of what
expressive inflections are are taken
and that seemed to me as i started work
with them
the element that we'd have to spend the
most time
uh convincing ourselves about
[Music]
i presume like any human being you get
stuck
at times feel like i don't know what to
do here i don't know where to turn
this material's not
working for me it's not playing out in a
way i hoped
or i don't know how to deal with this
material
for the moment anyway and i'm wondering
how you get
unstuck if you do and if you do get
stuck and also whether
um you're you
you think in some way that your very
broad knowledge of
vast amounts of repertoire out there
somehow open doors for you
yeah i think being stuck is is someplace
that
i spend a lot of time and i have a lot
of
after many years quite a few strategies
um
sometimes the best thing to do
is is to leave
leave the spot and really
walk away from it for a while
and then sometimes i wind up
treating it very provisionally and
arbitrarily and just writing a lot of
next steps
which uh which is partly a way of just
of
seeing what not to do um
but eventually i think usually
i wind up doing that thing
which i think it happens at some point
in every piece
of leaving the thing i can't solve until
the very last
problem in the piece um that is that
that painful that painful problem
will remain unsolved until it just
becomes
uh crux like i can't this piece will
never be unless i can do something here
um and sometimes the thing i do
is never quite right but
often it will be repaired later if
necessary
um i had a spot like that in my fifth
symphony where i
i needed i i came to a place where i
wanted to i felt like this would be a
big orchestral 2d
there already had been a couple big ones
in that piece
and i wrote one and i thought well i
finally faced up to it
and then just before i sent the piece
out as i was making the piano score the
piece i thought oh my gosh this sounds
very
manufactured and i replaced
a passage with probably about 4 000
notes with three chords
[Laughter]
which had not a very beautifully chosen
chord well they
i let me say they they they were they
were very welcome chords because
not as loose and i'd thought of at the
point i'd first become stuck
i thought that being unstuck meant
stepping up and
and you know just you know really really
powering powering it taking it to the
ground
instead it was a more scorched earth
kind of thing
and i really felt like that for once
that strategy of leaving it to the end
was worth it waiting for a better
solution
so john when you got stuck at that
moment
in the fifth symphony did
was it a technical problem or
one of inspiration or or are those
things inseparable
for you
i think it was a
place that i knew it i was working with
the text and it's working with a
sort of story and it seemed like such a
crucial point in the story
that i was trying to raise the bar i was
trying to
say something exceptional needs to
happen here
and already in a way that may not have
been a helpful
uh approach i probably needed to find
some way more organically which
eventually is what happened
and some way that also thinking more
theatrically
that is how could it happen more
concisely which it really didn't occur
to me at first
um so i think it was probably much more
that thing of drawing out of the piece
and going out of the inner ear
the inner ear always has lots of inner
things to say you know uh for just the
five people who might understand
understand them and back into the outer
ear which is the person who
is listening just for the immediate
impression of where they are in the
piece
and i think that was what was what was
necessary it's one of the things that
in teaching is easy to say to
young composers because they're so far
into the inner ear
that you your whole
task is to try to pull them out and say
hey people are also listening to this
that don't don't know where it's going
and are living it as it happens so
i think that that was what that's what
that whole problem was about
a lot of the pieces that you have
composed are sacred works
um and i'm wondering
if you hear or perceive
a difference between those works and
say you're purely orchestral works or
chamber pieces
the the presence of a text aside
um when you listen to the music or the
thinking process do you think that they
distinguish themselves if
for instance if someone were to listen
to a sacred piece of yours
and a so-called secular piece of yours
minus the words would someone perceive a
difference
well i like that question right because
i do
feel that
clearly the impulse the
the the guiding spirit of music
is is not secular
it it is mysterious and sort of not from
this world as we know it but
that said i do love things about the
premise of say
of sacred music and i've written
a lot of music for you in fact i thank
heaven so i've had a chance
to write this kind of music both
for manual for qatar singers in
situations
where the group and the audience are
ready to listen in what i take as a way
that one listens to this music
um the thing i like about sacred music
one of things
uh and i try to sort of mention it
sometimes to
certain of my colleagues be in in this
very positive
way is that it doesn't require
a an audible or demonstrative
stance from the listener
you don't applaud at the end of the vlog
cantata normally
um you don't have to applaud emote with
sacred motet
you can think what you think uh you can
receive it in the way that you receive
it
and i love moving it in that
way to a somewhat different arena
i've gotten so
um let's say
let's just say suspicious of the
standing o
and of of course even more of the what
we would call the crouching ovation
um which is which is that
in so many cases now become uh if you
don't offer the standing ovation it's a
deep insult to the performers you know
um all of this in sacred music
in principle is not a factor it's
because the audience is not
us it is us but it's not ultimately us
and that's one of the reasons that i've
felt very
privileged to be able to continue
working in that catalog
because i feel
like the pro the
the effort and the uh
and the invited listeners are a
different
in a different frame of mind and that's
a frame of mind i
really love to find myself in and find
listeners in
that is to say it's more contemplative
it's less judgmental it's more
willing to accept non-logical premises
uh premises requiring a leap
of some kind into something that we
can't
explain and that's why i guess probably
when you come down to it my favorite
music in the world
is in some way in that realm
um including some works by beethoven
composers you know who are not by
by general profession composer of sacred
music i mean
a shitz motet is speaking
to to listeners in another way
from a shasta government symphony
not to say that shastukovic is without
his own spiritual concerns but the
schutz motet is not asking
for a
certain love endorsement
from the hero
you are in very much in demand and have
been for many many years
with commissions uh sometimes you've
told me
that there are too much music to write
um
and that it's pressing on you in some
way but i'm wondering
but i also have the thought that you
find
time to compose pieces that no one is
asking for
that you do simply for your own
enjoyment and edification and i'm
wondering
how that balances out in your life
seems to have always been a balance i i
i'm always surprised to see how much
work
i've done all the way through that it
was not commissioned
there were just pieces that i had
decided to do and a lot of big pieces
the piece hour-long piece moteti de
montale
which i wrote as a volunteer uh song
cycle it's a wonderful
piece you've done wonderful performances
of in the in the instrumental version
that was
that when that got that big i began
thinking wow this is
this is a lot of a lot of music to try
to convince somebody to perform
um and i got a couple really good breaks
on that
with uh uh you know people saying okay
well we'll we'll do it but
um that's always the risk uh and lately
i've been doing much more
uh of that kind of work i haven't had as
many commissions but i've had a lot of
things that i've been thinking about
doing
um and one of them being
this thing that i've been constantly
putting off which i don't
write easily for piano it's always the
hardest thing for me and i've always
thought i should
i need to do it more to feel
less kind of uh
daunted by it less let's buffalo by the
prospect and that's sort of what i'm
trying to do now trying to feel more
that
um more that's the more that it's more
friendlier
friendlier world which means letting go
of the virtuosic side is that what you
are
focusing on now or i'm wondering do you
do you work on more than one piece at
once yeah i've wanted to keep projects
going because i
for when you get stuck it's good to have
another piece to move on to and i've
usually tried to keep that
option going so i have a couple other
things
i've got some jazz projects i've been
trying to write a big band piece for
two or three years and it just isn't
coming out very well
but i'm now thinking of trying to
salvage
whatever in it that did work um
and uh right i write a lot of pop tunes
um lately they've been quite abundant
and i've been
thinking about what i want to do with
them
and then i also have a
kind of nice relationship i hope it
continues nice so that getting the rice
has been a
terrific problem with a poet louise
glick
uh i've written quite a bit of music now
on her texts
and i have a new cycle uh which i've
been trying to get clear clear the use
of the poems
i have a few more poems of hers that i
have in mind
i really tend to stay with a writer for
a while until i feel like i've got
a grip um and i'm just getting that
with her poetry and i guess that
something more will go in that direction
i also really continue to write these
solo violin pieces anytime
someone writes me it once a kind of
honorific piece or
something to celebrate an anniversary or
something i've been writing a solo
violin piece
and it's now turned into a collection of
about six and i have another collection
coming along and that
seems to be a nice it's almost like a
diary
uh collection i did it years ago with
some
solo viola pieces says some way to keep
the thoughts
running um and one of the things i
miss doing uh is
uh is
large large large ensemble music i miss
it
only in principle because it's really
it's hard work
um but uh i'm
sort of i'm sort of keeping an eye out
for maybe one more shot
on some sort of a shorter works for
piece there's
something about the orchestral music
i've been hearing sometimes from the
younger composers around that
makes me think about the orchestra in a
somewhat different way
and it's a it's never been my
home the the large orchestra but it's
some
i look around and i think well i must
have spent quite a lot of time there i
got these big thick
thick scores sitting around um
and uh i think i'm not done with it i've
got something
i think i've got something left there
maybe a tuba concerto because
that was my best instrument when i was
when i was in high school um i think i
owe the
tuba some some some thought
well that they would have something
besides the vaughn williams concerto
there isn't so much for tuba and it's a
good it's a
it's a it's a composer friendly concerto
instrument because
you'll hear it and um
yeah having written everyone yeah having
your look at zero and yeah i mean i've
written
cello not so easy to be heard right
um i remember lucas foss gave me a
a um some unsolicited advice once on
cello concerto
i said i heard you're writing
intelligent choices so
maybe a little harp
that was the only safe thing he could he
could offer to me
that's right so john this is a
maybe too large a question i don't know
but you
this moment have a an idea of how
someone might describe
the arch of your compositional life up
to this point
from your years at princeton
studying with roger sessions um
kinds of changes in your musical
thinking are you
able to assess that or is that just
something that we have to do
i think the only formation
for sort of that kind of thinking that
i've ever been able to shape
is that when i was kid growing up
um i listened to the opera on the
weekends and i you know
imagined how they looked and i
subscribed to the opera news and so i
was a little opera
guy and i learned how a lot of operas
went and i thought this is what i
this is what i want to do i spent my
entire life running opera and
then i kind of started on my life and i
wrote a volunteer opera
no commission just wrote it um
and i have to admit it's a pretty
naughty piece but
it also has some stage value um
and the piece was tried out
quite well and i met i met a big
let's say an entity a powerful entity
and let's call it the opera world
which is different from the art of opera
and always has been
and i've found that opportunities
and further
activity in that field that i always
plan to be my major
we're not going to come easily and
so um and and it has been for lack of
of uh shall we say putting out the field
putting out the lines so as it is
i've written only a short opera and two
two
longer operas instead of what i expected
to be able to say at this point is that
i
at the end of my 12th opera i feel like
i
did exactly what i imagined doing when i
was a kid
and verdi right that was that was what i
thought this was what i thought i'd
really best cut out for
um so clearly the
shape of the ambition and the shape of
the world were not
contiguous um and that feels like a
regret
in a certain way and feels like the
bumpiest rides i've had
uh in terms of writing a piece and then
trying to get it out into the world have
always have
been having to do with opera from from
the very start
and i all i can say is i honor
maybe the people who persisted in that
world
are of tougher skin and heartier
constitution and more
persistent mentality than i and whatever
regrets i have
are always focused around that that sort
of chemical
you know the ship that sailed past um
i don't regret i'd have to say composing
the three operas was
was the most congenial i've ever felt
about any project
in all those cases i felt gee i really
know what i'm doing for once
you know i really think i see how to do
this
i've never i've never otherwise had that
feeling
on the other hand that has not been
what i felt was coming back
from the um from the profession
and i think it all came to a head
sitting
in a very
heavily staged extra rehearsal at the
chicago lyric
when the members of the company were
deciding or
not whether or not to eliminate
the final scene of the great gatsby
if there were ever a composer mind you
who
i thought of as clear-minded
and authoritative in his music it would
be
you i would i would recount a
tiny story that you wouldn't remember
many years ago after you had written
your first symphony
you kindly sent me a score and this is a
work i've conducted a few times since
then
but um i was looking at it and i
i had heard the first performance as
well
and i was looking at it and there was
this place
somewhere fairly early in the piece
where the trombone played a b-flat
and i remember having the audacity
to say to you john i i think that
b-flat's too
soon i think it needs to come
maybe not right there but you know two
beats later something like that
i don't know what it was i said and you
very
kindly said okay
and when i looked at the score as i have
when it was printed and have
used it to study this work i looked at
that moment and that b flat is still
there
as it probably should be so
um the opera world
if they're if they're
rearranging the queen of spades
of tchaikovsky or talking about removing
the last
scene from the great gatsby that's
a different level of of uh
involvement than my even than my saying
maybe not so soon on the b
flat oh yeah it is another
realm and probably should be on the
other hand it's
it's business and it's it's
the need to reach a public which is
incredibly vocal i david i was riding a
bus
i think it was ten years or eight years
after the gatsby
performances in new york and a guy came
up to me
and he said you know it'd be so much
better if you hadn't put
full time on stage at the end of that
act
you know that he comes out and scares
everybody i know and says
it's a it's just a really big dramatic
mistake we don't ever want to have to
see them on stage together like that
it's really
much better opera if you just hadn't
done that
i've never met this guy i never
had a conversation with him he was
there's a passionate
discussion on his part and i remember
thinking wow that's right
i mean that that experiences like that
have have continued ever since and
very few people relative to the
population saw that piece but
amazing people so many people have had
so many comments
years later that's both weird
and a great virtue of probably
probably the opera public is they they
nobody ever comes up to you
after a sing quartet as you know david
or a symphonic woman says
if only you would not
get rid of that and you gotta hit it you
know
um it's another it's another
mentality and i guess we should be
grateful for it but
it is it is truly a world
and it's why the opera public is so
distinct
to to that medium i think there are
people who
whose only musical a passion
is is that and i i get that i guess
because they own it you know
they really do so does your
chicago lyric opera story have a happy
ending
i don't mean the opera have a happy
ending we know it doesn't but
yeah and in fact they kept the scene
mainly because the cast likes singing it
the i've had that scene has followed me
around
um somebody
uh came up to me during the second run
at the met and said you know um
that i uh
i just i just hated your last scene so
much
you know um it just turned me against
the whole piece i
didn't like the opera much but it seemed
that last scene just really just just
is i said you know i hated it so much it
was this is right after performance
i had to buy another ticket and come
back back to see it again
you know because it i it was something
was haunting i could see the scene and
the
guys in the rain hats and the rain was
coming down to carrying the coffin
just it was haunting to me so i thought
i'd better come back and see it i'd
better see it
so i very i was very interested i said
yeah well you did wonderful i'm so glad
you did what did you think
i still hated it i still hated it
yeah but it's it's really interesting
being in an audience you know if you
were did you hear the time with the
premier
first performance of my brass concerto
and the guy comes out and sits next to
me i've got this ilc
so i can get go run backstage in the la
uh
in the old uh the old la place the
music hall yeah and uh he says i'm sorry
you know um
he says i i would like that seat of
yours
because if i've been told that this
first piece will be quite unpleasant
and if i if necessary i would like to be
able to leave easily
so i said well okay uh
you know what what am i to say i've one
scene over i'll just go
and put him in the aisle seat so he took
the seat
and we listened to the piece yep
and your piece yeah yeah and
and we get to about halfway through the
last moon which is where they told me to
head for the door so i could get
backstage to go on stage
so at that point i crawled over the guy
said i said to him i can't take it
anymore
myself
[Laughter]
and then and then i went on stage and of
course i wasn't very far from him
and he was still sitting there yeah the
aisle
he had kind of a grin on his face he
kind of got it but but it was
it was too perfect it was like you know
it was like one of those
one of those all-time perfect setups
john for me and i think many people who
will
watch this this has been a wonderful
conversation and
i'm grateful to you for your taking your
time out of your composing and you're
practicing
art of fugue um which we'll let you get
back to
um thank you so much john harbeson it's
great to see you
as always it's a great pleasure to talk
with you moteti di montale was a work he
wrote originally
for voice and piano it's an hour-long
work in
four large sections over the years he
orchestrated the
piece for an ensemble of
10 11 instruments and collagen music
did the first complete performance of
the whole cycle
and we ended up recording it
with two different singers and the
ensemble
and i think to get to hear
even one or two movements of this very
intense beautiful cycle of poems by
eugenio
montale will be a
a great treat a great blessing
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
keep me
my
[Music]
hey
you